und jetzt kommen wir zu einer Geschichte
die ist wirklich unglaublich man muss so
so so viel Pech haben und dann kriegst
du ein Junge auch wirklich noch einen
Schock ein Junge der diesen Traktor
gefahren hat in Weilerswist in
Nordrhein-Westfalen ein 16-Jähriger und
der hat bei der Hitze auf dem Feld
geholfen hat den Traktor oder
stundenlang über das Feld gefahren und
dann das dann hat er sich weit und breit
leider den einzigen Strommast ausgesucht
der dort eine 110.000 Volt
Stromleitungen durchführt dieser Mast
umgeknickt aber das noch lange nicht
alles riesige Folgen für 10.000
Stromkunden 65.000 Menschen vier Stunden
lang und teilweise länger ohne Strom was
für eine Geschichte Tim Specks unser
Bild Reporter ist genau dort in
Weilerswist vor dem wie man unschwer
erkennen kann immer noch geknickten
Strommast dort und mich interessiert vor
allen Dingen dieser 16-Jährige dieses
Traktor Kind dieser Traktor Tini wie
konnte dem das passieren ehrlicherweise
ich leide ein bisschen mit
[Musik]
ja wir leiden hier irgendwie alle so ein
bisschen mit ich war eben im Dorf
unterwegs sag mal gefragt wie wie steht
der zu dieser ganzen Sachen die sagt
natürlich auch alle Anwohner ja es ist
ein unglaublich wir können euch mal
dieses riesige Feld jetzt zeigen ja es
ist wirklich ein unglaublich weites Feld
und der steht genau ein Strommast und in
genau diesen Strommast ist der arme
Junge reingefahren er hat das gestern
gegenüber diesen Anwohnern indem wir
eben sprechen konnten so begründet
angeblich sei die Lenkung blockiert
gewesen und darüber hinaus auch die
Bremse das heißt er wollte eigentlich
relativ nah an diesem was dran fahren
und dann eben relativ nah daran entlang
melden kurz vorher hat aber die Lenkung
blockiert und dann konnte er nicht mehr
ausweichen ist in diesem Mast hat ihn
wie ihr seht komplett umgehauen diese
Mähdrescher und dann kam auch das Pech
zu diesem Schock der Strom der hängt
natürlich an der Leitung runter und der
arme Junge hatte dann gesagt auch noch
Angst selber irgendwie ein Stromschlag
zu bekommen weil er eben diese Leitung
lag er ist dann trotzdem rausgesprungen
es ist alles gut soweit gut und die
Polizei die behandelt das ganze das ist
auch ganz interessant auch wenn es auf
diesem Feld passiert ist übrigens ganz
normalen Verkehrsunfall er wird also
jetzt ein Brief bekommen von der Polizei
da muss man sich dann äußern also egal
ob man beim Vordermann drauf fährt oder
eben ein riesigen Strommast umbenennst
das scheint die Polizei erstmal dass
zumindest hier klar der Strommast ist
nicht Schuld ne also mal sehen kann man
es in dem Fall leider nicht schieben Tim
Specks unser Bild Reporter danke dir
[Musik]